conviene questo rumore secondo voi
dovrei rispondere a questo telefono che
cosa era pronto ma che sta facendo anita
pronto
ma di cosa stai parlando che intruso
[Musica]
vitale avuto un'idea che io a di salire
su e controllare se il lupo e su devo
prendere qualcosa da portar via lugo che
cosa gli vuoi portare al lupo beh potrei
portargli da mangiare un solo berlino e
il merlino posso prendere questo in
prestito
prometto ok lo prendo come un figlio
grazie per questi bacini devo solo
portarlo al lupo al piano di sopra
almeno credo che sia un lupo al piano di
sopra
ok ve lo riporto fra poco tuo aspetto
acqua però perché potrebbe spaventarti
io salgo su ci vediamo dopo i referenti
qualche rumore strano raggiungimi ok si
si io starò qui a sorvegliare merlino
vendite questi rumori
se nessuno dei rumori strani che sentite
anche voi e il lupo che qui sei nella
stanza da cui uscivano delle mani strane
che ci sia qualcuno li nella stanza vi
ricordate quella stanza c'è nessuno e il
lupo
vengo in pace non voglio farti del male
[Musica]
qualcosa e il lupo stai sgranocchiando
qualcosa o qualcuno
se nessuno
c'era poca di qualcosa o qualcuno di un
lupo o di un lupo mannaro
tieni sono venuto qua per portarti un
giochino tieni
presso il giochino quindi forse vuole
fare amicizia e il lupo
ora che ti ho dato il giochino vuoi
uscire fuori da quella porta
mi sa che non è molto amichevole
scappare il motivo di tale c'è qualcosa
qua di dare ai tre giorni si parla
sempre di soffitto c'è qualcosa si è
portato da che cosa c'è che cosa hai
visto il gioco di berlino
gliel'ho dato è la presa
aveva dei denti supera guti penso che
sia un lupo un lupo mannaro oppure un
cane gigante un lupo dobbiamo fare
qualcosa
il giardino è andato in giardino lo
senti è appena uscito in giardino o
forse il cane dei vicini
il cane dei vicini un una cosa io ho
un'idea che come tu non mi credi siccome
la scorsa volta il lupo è arrivato
mentre io ero sulla ma che in giardino
andrai tu sull'amata in giardino io ti
guarderò da qua e aspetterò fino a che
non vedrò al lupo
secondo me non arriverà però mi piace
molto l'idea della ma che in giardino
quindi sì perché no bene ok
mettiti nella moka chiudi gli occhi fai
silenzio che i kenioti riserverò dalla
finestra
va bene devo dire che è molto comoda
però se ti senti in pericolo
urla ok ok tutto pronto per sorvegliare
il giardino e vitale sono qua di fronte
alla finestra e controllerò bene se si
avvicina qualche creatura qualche lupo
vediamo ma non si vede niente
[Musica]
dovevo tagliare queste non si vede
niente
dovevo togliere questi ok finalmente
vedo qualcosa sembra tutto tranquillo
per ora
fate anche voi se vedete qualcosa ma
vitale si è addormentato che ho detto di
chiudere gli occhi non di addormentarsi
ora se arriva il lupo non se ne
accorgerà nemmeno forse si sta muovendo
qualcosa
[Musica]
che cos'è quello devo andare a salvare
vitale qualcosa sta bloccando la porta
merlino che cos'è c'è qualcosa qua
dietro la porta
vediamo se si vede qualcosa qua che
cos'è
c'è qualcosa dietro lo senti berlino
dimmi che cos'è secondo voi devo provare
ad aprire la porta o può essere
pericoloso beh almeno berlino qualche mi
protegge anche berlino sta bloccando la
porta proviamo ad aprirla se vediamo
dobbiamo per forza aprirla vitale in
pericolo se nessuno se nessuno qua
berlino chiuso la porta
non devo aprirla ma dobbiamo andare a
salvare vitale come facciamo un nuovo
forse avvolti da che non devo aprire la
porta e se il lupo fosse arrivato si sta
aprendo da sola
per lanciato qualcosa è finito qua sotto
che cos'è berlino il tuo giochino no
music io tu non mangiato quasi tutto in
un quadro ha segnato quasi tutto il
gioco di berlino forse ha solo fame
allora ed è arrivato qua per trovare
qualcosa da mangiare
vediamo se ancora dietro alla porta poi
un po per caso mai fame
parlino lo vedi anche tu che cos'è un
paio un lupo che cos'è voi qualcosa da
mangiare a voi nuovamente il giochino di
berlino
purtroppo non posso darcelo adesso
perché c'è la berlino non rubi arti blu
che se vuoi posso darti per quell'altro
da mangiare va bene va bene
qualcos'altro
ok che cosa passata questa quest'altro
sannino non ho niente da mangiare qua
purtroppo è il berlino non offenderti ok
lo so berlino
questo giochino e va bene allora tu
tieni questo e io gli do questo bene
berlino sembra molto tranquillo
ok lupo allora ti do questo giochino che
il grano cotto e mangiato ieri senti
però non mangiarmi la mano ok dai molto
attento tieni
[Musica]